[Music]
so in this video i kicked it off with a
hack to making your bananas baking ready
by putting them in the oven it really
helps soften it up and get it that nice
like puree texture if they're kind of
baked off and those sugars can really
help soften up the banana now i chose to
use banana
because of the popularity of the fruit
bananas are the most widely grown and
eaten fruit in the world so i know that
more people are going to have access to
this ingredient because they are just so
available which is a big part of our
process here at tc is thinking not only
about what is great and delicious but
also
what do people have access to and what's
like maybe already on your kitchen
counter that you want to just like throw
into a recipe
this style of muffin is actually
inspired by a french pastry where excuse
my french i'll probably butcher the
pronunciation but it's tigra which is
like tiger and i think it's because by
adding the chocolate sprinkles it kind
of looks like it has tiger stripes now
that pastry is actually a tea cake where
it's like a little
final ca that has the chocolate
sprinkles and it's sometimes filled with
chocolate ganache and i thought it was
such a cool pastry that i'd never
actually seen around in america and
adopting the same stylistic
characteristics and transferring it into
a muffin which people are probably more
likely to be familiar with and want to
make at home
so just like the tiger i use the
chocolate sprinkles just to give that
cool striped feeling to the dessert and
then once the muffins came out the oven
i used just the back of a wooden spoon
to create a little hole and fill that
with chocolate ganache so kind of like
elevated the breakfast muffin to like a
next level
little
delectable thing
don't know what to call it
but they're good that's all that matters
so there's a joke in tasty about how
much i bake with bananas considering
they are far from my favorite fruits now
i'm not a complete banana hater i just
don't like them once they are
ripened but i keep my personal prejudice
aside because i know literally planet
earth loves bananas more than anything
and there's actually a lot of wastes
tied to bananas because once they reach
a certain point most people think that
they're inedible and want to toss them
in the trash so my first tasty video i
ever did was actually four different
ways to bake with ripe bananas literally
millions of bananas are tossed out every
day because people think that they're
too ripe and they don't like how they
look and funny enough the ripe bananas
are the ones you want to bake with so
if you have ripe bananas in your house
and you're like ugh i don't want to eat
that i feel you i understand put it in
the freezer bake with it later and you
can make some muffins
[Music]
this recipe was a journey
this is not a pour
so here's where trouble is right now
so this recipe took a lot of development
to nail down i mean
the amount of math and science figuring
out
volume of battery i needed for the whole
cake what i'm going to do is plop my
calculator
and figure out
within my two cups of chocolate amongst
four bowls and divided so i can properly
scale up
as well as how much stabilizer i needed
in order for the colors to not bleed
into each other
oh
oh to the top
the simplest way to approach this recipe
is i wanted to make one mother batter
for every color of the cheesecake and
then divide it into
four different bowls that way each bowl
got its own quantity of chocolate to
create a different tone of brown just
get in there
i feel like these are almost too close
in color
so maybe just a little bit more
so it can be very distinguished
part of the difficulty was just the
mechanics of
filming while cooking because when i
would put down a bowl to change camera
lenses
the batter itself would actually start
to set so the idea is to like pour them
all into the pan this is not
but you have to change the container
yeah so i'll put it into a
microwave-proof container
let's get started on fire
and 15 seconds
great yeah solutions by relay so each
batter has to remain kind of loose and
warm up until it's all done and then it
can go into the fridge and set so a tip
that i learned was
while making this cheesecake at any
point you have to stop or take a break
microwave the batter for 20 seconds or
so just to get it re-fluid before you
start pouring and wait until you have a
window time to pour all four colors
before you do it because if you pour
layer one and then take a break and then
try to pour layer two it's not gonna
push out and you're not gonna get a nice
beautiful even ring so it definitely
requires your full attention while
making fingers crossed for layer three
just like ready we're ready for you
layer three one layer three
we're living in like the twilight zone
right now you did it
this cheesecake is definitely one of the
more aspirational desserts i've made
it requires a lot of attention to detail
and patience so if you are a hobby baker
and you just want to like dedicate an
afternoon to making something like
really stunning and beautiful for your
friends or family for any occasion this
is definitely a fun recipe to like take
on as a challenge i really
have a genuine interest of knowing what
other flavors can be made with this
cheesecake so if you do make another
flavor please let us know pop in the
comments and
maybe i'll give it a try too
[Music]
this recipe is a total throwback to my
childhood back in elementary school we
had these magazines where you could
order christmas gifts for people and
they had this four flavored cheesecake
where it was four individual cheesecakes
cut up into quarters but all put
onto one piece of cardboard and i
figured i could probably try to make it
all in one pan
so what made this cheesecake a bit
tricky is that i wanted to divide up
four very liquidy fluid items the thing
that made the most sense to me was to
use ingredients that were already in a
cheesecake so i opted for graham
crackers so once i got through the
structural part of the recipe the next
challenge was the four flavors
cheesecakes are really fun because you
can flavor them with whatever you want
but each different flavoring component
has its own chemistry so each cheesecake
batter end up having its own texture and
consistency so i had to play around with
every single flavor to make sure
one it tasted really good because end of
day doesn't matter what a dessert looks
like if it does not taste good it
doesn't really matter and then also that
it was thick enough where once i put it
in its corner it didn't budge it stayed
put
but it was still like nice and creamy
once it was all set
when it came to choosing flavors the
number one obvious one was chocolate
i love chocolate everyone loves
chocolate and chocolate hazelnut spread
is really thick and creamy so i knew
once i fold it into the cheesecake
batter is gonna be really thick and it
would fold up now the other flavors not
so easy the second flavor i wanted to go
with was lemon because it's a non-baked
cheesecake i think lemon is a really
good bright fresh flavor it's like very
summery and it's honestly one of my
favorites so i use lemon curd because if
i put in lemon juice it would have been
way too runny and then i just added a
little bit more lemon curd on the top to
make it visually pleasing the third
flavor i used was
just for the plain jeans in the world
everyone needs something simple so i
just did a vanilla cheesecake but to
give it like a little bit more oomph and
make it just as pretty as everything
else i added some raspberry jam vanilla
berries classic combination so i just
swirled in the top to make it very
pretty and then added some fresh berries
on the edge
now the fourth and final flavor
ruined me
it the fourth and final flavor was meant
to be caramel
but the consistency of that varied so
much between every product i use some
were super runny some were so thick i
could even fold them in and it was
really tough when i was testing this
recipe i thought the cheesecake was done
it was beautiful and then as we're
filming the beauty shots the caramel
completely fell apart it literally was
oozing out of the side of the pan
because there's way too much water in it
but our lovely friends in brazil have
created a great food product called
dolce de leche which has a very similar
taste to caramel but it's so smooth and
thick so once i figured to use that it
was smooth sailing from there
and all the flavors
were good to go
i wanted people to have the option of
having that like prized double flavor
slice of cheesecake where you cut a
quarter inch of what's on the left and
quarter on the right and you have like a
two for one special however i think all
the flavors go really well together but
i had to check so i tested double
forkfuls of all the flavors just to see
what went and the only one that really
didn't go too well was a lemon curd and
chocolate so in the final cheesecake i
put them on opposing ends and then
everything else was good from there the
most struggling part about developing
this recipe
was to make it simple i wanted to be
like very all levels friendly
it's easy to make things complicated
it's difficult to make them simple it's
my philosophy of recipe development this
video didn't take long at all to do
wow
took like a day
full play the cheesecake
cool